normally when a hurricane is barreling
towards us we tend to run the other way
but not ila she's a leatherback turtle
who was meandering off the coast of
Virginia when she accidentally swam
straight into hurricane Florence
scientists were worried she'd get caught
up in the middle of the storm but ila
managed to survive by swimming towards
deeper waters turns out there's a part
of hurricanes we don't often think about
what happens under the surface and Isla
is just one example
far out see fish that live near the
surface might feel some turbulence as a
storm passes but most sea creatures
including dolphins whales and sharks
avoid the rough surface water and swim
to calmer seas but it's a different
story near shore changes in water
temperature and salinity can be
catastrophic for marine life hurricanes
can generate massive waves which mix
warm surface water with cooler saltier
water below generating currents that
extend up to 91 meters below the surface
these currents are so strong that they
can sweep manatees inland into canals
and ponds or away from coastal waters
all together and into the open ocean
where they can become disoriented and
even die
hurricanes also bring heavy rains so
fresh water often floods coastal areas
and because fresh water is less dense
than saltwater it sits on top of the
salt water like oil on vinegar where it
can prevent oxygen from reaching the
salty layer below and disrupt salinity
levels which can lead to sores lesions
and ultimately death in whales dolphins
and porpoises hurricanes can also kick
up dirt and sand in shallow seas which
can kill fish by clogging their gills
experts think that this is probably one
of the factors that killed an estimated
nine point four million saltwater fish
in 1992 during Hurricane Andrew the
dirty murky water also blocked sunlight
from reaching corals and sea grass in
fact scientists found that coral cover
in the Caribbean decreases on average by
17 percent a year after a hurricane
strikes and that's in addition to the
stress coral already face from human
interference from things like global
warming or pollution but hurricanes are
not always bad news for sea life believe
it or not after Hurricane Katrina
damaged or destroyed 90% of fishing
boats in the Mississippi sound
scientists observed a huge increase
in dolphin births without all the
fishing boats around often suddenly
found themselves with tons of fish all
at their disposal and their populations
thrived and of course hurricanes impact
land animals too sometimes they change
ecosystems altogether
for instance the Hawaiian island of
Kauai II is now inundated with feral
chickens locals say they are the
descendants of domesticated chickens
that escaped when hurricanes blew open
coops and in North Carolina torrential
rains from Hurricane Florence
overwhelmed more than 100 hog waste
lagoons possibly releasing pig waste
into the local water supply
unfortunately research indicates that
the intensity of hurricanes will only
increase with climate change so if we
don't get a handle on it soon we'll be
in some deep pig waste we'll be in some
deep pig waste